new york city at night just hours after
the completion of game one of a yankees
mets double header and some hour and a
half's worth of a rain delay the jackie
robinson day celebration continues as a
part of the doubleheader between these
crosstown rivals everybody wears number
42 tonight including the mets and
yankees who wore their traditional
numbers in the opener yankees in first
at home in yankee stadium it's just
strange kind of weird david peterson on
the mound for the mets making his fifth
start of the year good numbers for the
rookie southpaw voight frazier and hicks
to start things out for the yankees and
there's a line shot that carries all the
way out to right conforto just shy of
the track man we're used to seeing fly
balls go in this ballpark especially in
that direction clint frazier had an
outstanding game one uh right there
great pitch another change up away to
get the strikeout here's aaron hicks now
literally throws the hands at it and
lines it to right for conforto jonathan
lawisigo will start on the mound for the
yankees 25 year old right hander will
make his third starting assignment of
the year here's michael conforto now had
a good opener in the doubleheader
wow sprays it into the opposite field
and the mets will have a runner at
second base with one gun to start their
half of the first
that's when you know a guy's hot this
guy's been really impressive too dominic
smith looking to pick up an early rbi
with a man at second and two gone served
into the opposite field and off the wall
talkman plays it off to bounce conforto
being waved around
they've got smith in a rundown between
first and second
where he is tagged out
i know he's wearing 42 but that didn't
look like jackie robinson tyrostrada now
after the lead off walk first yankee
base runner of the game that's passed
alonso into the right field corner
mercer runs well he'll get into third
base and here come the yankees with
runners at the corners and nobody out so
now it's the catcher eric kratz who won
the first pitch lines it into left field
to tie the ball game the 40 year old
veteran cashing in on his first rbi of
the season faces are loaded with a run
in and one away now for aaron hicks
hicks shoots it into the hole on the
right side one run will score
and the yankees have taken a 2-1 lead so
now gary sanchez with the bases loaded
sanchez has had four at-bats this year
with the bases loaded all four have
resulted in strikeouts and he loses
sanchez on four pitches to walk in a run
mike talkman digging in
talkman bounces it on one hop to mcneil
to guillerme for one and it could have
been a lot worse for the new york mets
here's the rookie catcher ali sanchez
and a base hit
alice sanchez's first
career major league hit
oh and two the count to michael conforto
too late tried to take time instead he
strikes out swinging argue with the up
you never take your hand off the bat
kids you just say time time time he
doesn't give it to you then you don't
get it there's jordy mercer now with one
away
at the shallow center field and that's
going to drop into no man's land there's
tyro estrada now with one out and one on
finally got him
good pitch right there in 1936 in berlin
germany he was a sprinter and guys he
finished
second in the 200 meters as dom smith
sends a ball up and over here for a
ground world double so he continues to
be red hot alonso trying to pick up a
base runner dom smith who doubled and
then advanced to third ball in two
strikes
struck him out with a high gas nothing
comes with a one out double
to that crack bat that was pete snap
there's aaron hicks now with one on one
on
jerks that one into the corner that's
going to bounce around in front of
conforto voigt to third and the yankees
have runners in scoring position with
one out in the fifth big opportunity now
for gary sanchez
got him how does gary sanchez get out of
this
he gets out of it by not being coddled
i'm sorry you're not hitting you're not
helping us you're sitting right next to
me till you figure it out mike talkman
was intentionally walked by the way to
load the bases and face miguel and
duhart sharply hit the shortstop for
guillermo he goes the short way to cut
down a runner and the yankees leave him
loaded in the fifth two balls with no
strikes this account to brandon nimmo
nimo a notoriously patient hitter
see something he likes here and drives
it to deep left field over the glove of
mike talkman that'll bring in guillerme
and it's a one-run game oh is it tough
order when a team's trying to come back
against one of the elite closers in
modern baseball that's a role this
chapman a couple of things at work here
for luis rojas a pinch runner and a
pinch hitter you saw me rosario digging
in for luis guillory and billy hamilton
pinch running in first base
stolen basically
oh yeah he's gone he's got that bag it
doesn't matter if you throw behind him
with a lead like that chapman hasn't
thrown him a strike this is a guy that
you got to come right after
oh rosario sends a ball to deep left and
gone
as the home team in the bronx
the mets have walked off the new york
yankees
and inning away from snapping their
six-game losing streak
and ahmed rosario as a pinch hitter
walks them off across town